[Music]
on this Tuesday night food inflation and
deflating discounts on expiring items
it's not fair fresh criticism for
Canada's biggest grosser and the calls
for an investigation if it's not
illusion I don't know what that is New
Revelations about the Saskatchewan
stabbing Rampage what the victim's
families just learned from political
victory in Iowa to legal trouble in New
York what's next from Donald
Trump and cooking up success a Canadian
Chef turned actor's Journey from Rock
Bottom to the Emmy
Awards global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with news
about inflation what it's doing to your
cost of living plus what it could mean
for interest rates Canada's annual
inflation rate accelerated 3.4% in
December at a bit faster than the 3.1%
rise in November it's largely driven by
the price of gas which didn't drop as
quickly as it did in December of 2022 as
well airfare vehicles and rent drove
inflation higher last month it's a big
Improvement on where we were a year ago
but with inflation sticking around
interest rates are likely to stick too
more on that in just a moment but we
begin with what it means for putting
food on your table and why one big
grocery store chain is reducing its
popular Deep Discount Abigail ban has
our top story
tonight as a single mom of two young
kids it's kind of hor horrible like
horrific strong opinions from Shoppers
about L Blah's latest move to shrink
discounts on expiring Foods where some
stores offered 50% off now it's only 30
it's not fair because if they throw it
away the M as well give a discount would
you buy it if it's 30% no I will not
yeah any reason just uh
the number one grosser in our country
has missed a clear opportunity to read
the room syan charab says lbla told his
research lab the move was made to match
competitors he calls that disturbing if
it's not collusion I don't know what
that is now there's still a chance to
get this 30% off salad for 50% off and
that's through an app called Flash Food
the catch is you can't see the food
before you buy it so let's take a look
at what we found we got that salad for
50% off this spring mix well it's a
little slimier than I would have liked
and I don't think I would have picked
that up if I had been in the store to
try it first it was $199 and then we
have this mixed box of produ all of this
for $5 let's see oh I think that's a
mango with some serious bruising on it
otherwise a lot of food in here for $5
the whole purchase was $0.48 but we
didn't get to check it out in store
first I did download the app and it's a
thought it's a definite thought the
liberal government has has long promised
to hold big Grocers to account the idea
that you would simply ask politely and
have the grocery chains that are engaged
heavily in food price gouging and
profiting enormously that is simply
wrong-headed new Democrats want the
competition Bureau to investigate the
agency tells Global News it's aware of
the discount change but can't say if
it's doing anything about it the
industry Minister's office says new
inflation numbers show food prices are
stabilizing they were 4.7% higher
year-over-year
that's the same as the month before I
mean it just feels like another
manifestation of corporate greed which
is increasing food and security on
campus our food bank has se a 250%
increase in users for its part labla has
ignored four requests for comment from
Global News Abel bman Global News
Ottawa well it's too early to declare
Victory on inflation in Canada and if
you were hoping for a quick drop in
interest rates you're likely going to
have to wait our senior business
correspondent an gabiola is here with
some analysis
an the central bank is widely expected
to hold its Benchmark interest rates
steady at 5% at its next announcement on
January 24th beyond that economists are
divided some say we could see interest
rate Cuts this spring others say we'll
have to wait until summer and all of
that depends on whether the economy
remains weak add to this a series of
geopolitical crises that have stoked
inflation the war in Ukraine and
escalating conflicts that have added to
shipping cost of vessels re-rooting
around the Red Sea according to the
Canadian Chamber of Commerce Supply
Chain risks and disruptions have caused
companies to prioritize security over
efficiency they're keeping more
inventory on shelves to guard against
shortages and this creates structural
inflation meaning we may have to get
used to inflation that's higher than
what we're used to think of it as The
New Normal the central bank's quest to
tame inflation has been likened to a
long race where the last kilometer is
the toughest Donna all right and gaviola
in Toronto thank you it is the end of a
political era in Alberta former Premier
Rachel notley who has led the NDP in
Alberta since 2014 and formed the First
new democrat government in that
province's history says she is stepping
down if there is any one accomplishment
that I can leave behind me it's that we
are not a one- party Province where
albertans have no real choice about how
their province is to be run Alberton do
not ever have to feel that elections and
their opinions do not matter it was that
way when I started it's not that way
anymore notley made history in May 2015
when she led the NDP to Victory ending
more than four Decades of progressive
conservative rule in Alberta she was
Premier until 2019 when the United
conservative party won and she became
leader of the opposition notley will
stay on as party leader until a
successor is chosen in Saskatchewan the
coroners inquest into the massacre at
James Smith cre nation and the village
of Weldon her detailed accounts of the
terrible events RCMP released new
details of what unfolded in the early
morning hours of September 4th 2022 the
suspect attacking many of the victims as
they woke up Heather uck West reports in
a warning some of the details in her
story are
upsetting a grandfather who died
protecting his grandson a mother who
survived an initial attack murdered
mured while tending to her dying son on
the second day of a Coroner's inquest
into the mass killings on the James
Smith creation and Welden Saskatchewan
family members heard new and
heartbreaking details about how their
loved ones died Brian buggy Burns lost
his wife and son in the attacks it was
very hard especially for my son when
he's 15 and he was part of the attacks
too got St great here so yeah he's he's
having a tough time today the RCMP once
again confirmed confirming what Global
News first reported last year that Damen
Sanderson originally reported by police
as a suspect in the mass killings had in
fact been mil sanderson's first victim
he would go on to kill 10 more people
injuring 17 others he also threatened to
kill his own teenage son the young life
saved by Earl burns my sanderson's
father-in-law RCMP also presented a
timeline of the days leading up to the
mass killings telling the inquest that
community members knew mil Sanderson was
in and around the James Smith creation
engaging in illegal activities and
wanted by police maybe some of his
family and friends knew that he was
there like uh I can believe that but
leadership we're we're not aware of that
Community leaders say they had no idea
that my Sanderson a man with a long and
violent criminal history had been
released from prison on parole their
lawyer says that's because there's no
duty to inform leadership which they
hope this inquest will change First
Nations indigenous groups are really not
treated as equal Partners in the justice
system as other governments when it
comes to uh Corrections and justice for
their own members the parole board of
Canada is expected to defend its
decision to release SM Sanderson before
his sentence was complete in the coming
days a separate inquest into sanderson's
death which occurred in police custody
will take place next month Donna all
right Heather uck West in melord
Saskatchewan tonight thanks Heather
British columb Ians are being warned to
plan ahead and stay off the roads as
another round of winter weather is
forecast for the southern half of that
Province overnight snowfall and winter
storm warning stretch from BC's South
Coast to the Alberta border and North to
Prince George as much as 30 cmers of
snow is expected and freezing rain could
be a factor in parts of Greater
Vancouver and Vancouver Island further
East Northern Alberta and parts of
Saskatchewan are still under extreme
cold warnings and a patchwork of winter
storm snow squalls and wind War warnings
are in place for southern Ontario and
Atlantic
Canada it is winter in New York
Philadelphia and Washington those cities
got the first significant snowfall in
nearly two years an Arctic blast is
covering large swats of the US in the
South more than half a million children
were told to stay home today as frigid
temperatures stretched well into Texas
Alabama and parts of the Florida
Panhandle ice is the main concern in the
Pacific Northwest where tens of
thousands of people are still without
power after a weekend storm at least
seven weather related deaths have been
reported in the US and more than 3,000
flights have been cancelled Republican
voters braved the cold and the snow last
night to cast their ballots in the Iowa
caucuses and as was widely predicted
former president Donald Trump won in a
[Applause]
landslide Trump won 50% of the vote
that's well ahead of his closest
Republican Challengers who were more
than 30 points behind Trump has the
momentum heading into the New Hampshire
primary next week as Jackson prco
explains the only question now is
whether anyone can catch
up never before has a candidate won Iowa
by such a wide margin Donald Trump made
history without breaking a sweat and I
really think this is time now for
everybody our country to come together
though turnout was down sharply Trump's
grip on Iowa Republicans was was never
really in question he's not a swamp
creature like our previous presidents
we're just going through the motions and
that President Trump is the
nominee his closest Rivals Ronda santis
and Nikki Haley effectively tied for a
very distant second place they'll push
on to the New Hampshire primary anyway
in hopes they might somehow pull off the
impossible we represent a chance to
reverse the madness that we've seen in
this country our campaign is the last
best hope of stopping the Trump Biden
nightmare there may not be much of a
fight left Trump's legal troubles
including 91 criminal charges and a
civil suit have only improved his
standing with Republicans he was back in
court for a defamation trial straight
from Iowa that really reads into the
narrative that he's out there taking the
shots for you and these primary voters
believe that the question is will
general election voters believe it
[Music]
afraid of turning off Republicans do
santis and Haley have positioned
themselves as Trump without the drama
running against a man whose policies
they largely support vowing to support
him if he wins the nomination why would
you go for an alternative to me when you
can have the real thing it all pretends
a 2024 election that feels a lot like
2020 Trump versus Joe Biden a historic
matchup between two incumbent candidates
next week's New Hampshire primary will
be a far bigger test of Trump's grip on
the party Nikki Haley has focused much
of her campaigning in that state where
the primary captures a far broader
segment of Republicans than the Iowa
caucuses Donna okay Jackson in
Washington thanks Iran launches multiple
missile attacks coming up who is being
targeted and what does it
[Music]
signal in maius a cyclone drenched the
island nation with tr IAL rain and
caused flash floods supermarkets were
swamped and many schools closed
hospitals were only able to keep their
emergency departments open the same
storm system swept through the French
island of reunion on Monday where people
were warn to shelter at home the Cyclone
is being blamed for at least two deaths
tensions in the Middle East have been
further inflamed by a series of attacks
launched by Iran Iran says its missiles
and drones hit Southwest Pakistan and
what it claims is the the base of a
militant group opposed to tyan and
overnight at least eight Iranian
ballistic missiles hit herbal the
capital of Iraq's Kurdistan region as
well Iranian missiles hit Targets in
Northern Syria Iran has said it wants to
avoid a larger regional conflict but as
Redmond Shannon reports that's exactly
what it appears to be
stoking Rockets fired from Iran and into
Iraq not something entirely new but it
is another St step of escalation in the
Middle East increasingly focused around
Iran the ballistic missiles killed at
least four people including prominent
businessman pesr dii and his baby
daughter tan says the targeted building
in the Iraqi Kurdish city of irbil was
an Israeli spy base an Israeli
government official refused to comment
on those claims so I'm not going to
speculate on uh reports coming from uh
beyond our borders the Kurdish Region's
leader refused Ed Iran's claims all of
the allegations that they have uh made
are baseless well what's surprising we
are not a part of this conflict we don't
know why Iran is retaliating against
civilians of Kurdistan Iran says the
strikes were in retaliation for a
suspected Israeli strike that killed a
senior commander of Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard in Syria last month
on Monday Iran also hit what it says
were Islamic State targets inside Syria
apparent revenge for this month's
Islamic State suicide bombings at the
anniversary Memorial of revolutionary
Guard general kasum salamani those
attacks in southern Iran killed at least
94 people and on Tuesday Iranian State
media said tan struck two bases of an
anti-iranian militant group inside
neighboring Pakistan Iran funds Hamas in
Gaza and Hezbollah in Lebanon both of
which want to eliminate the state of
Israel Tran also sends arms to houi
rebels in Yemen they are currently
attacking Merchant ships in the Red Sea
in response to Israel's war in Gaza the
US Navy said Tuesday it intercepted an
arms shipment coming from Iran this week
Iran's foreign minister criticized us
support for Israel telling Washington
war is not the solution Redmond Shannon
Global News London Ukrainian President
Vladimir zalinski is in Davos speaking
to world leaders trying to ensure his
country's long war with Russia is not
forgotten in his speech he called for
peace and unlike last year he did not
directly appeal for more weapons instead
he warned world leaders Russian
President Vladimir Putin intends to
expand Beyond Ukraine if anyone thinks
this is only about
us this is only about
Ukraine they are are fundamentally
mistaken zinsky also pressed leaders to
help rebuild his War torn country he
thanked allies for stricter sanctions on
Russia but urged leaders to limit
workarounds for imports of banned
Western Products zinsky speech comes at
a difficult time on the battlefield
Ukraine's counter offensive last year
was largely unsuccessful and Western
donor fatigue has set in National
Security concerns ahead what could stop
Canadian researchers from receiving
Federal
[Music]
funding
the federal government has named more
than 100 foreign research institutions
it claims May pose a threat to National
Security it includes Chinese Iranian and
Russian organizations which are believed
to have ties to military National
Defense or State security entities in
their respective countries David Aken
breaks down the list what it means for
Canadian researchers and how it's being
received David well Donna here's the
list of the named research organizations
it's 11 pages long 108 foreign
institutions six from Russia 12 from
Iran and 85 from China among the
institutions banned from partnering with
Canadian researchers using Federal
funding the Beijing Computing science
research center the nanging Army command
college and China's Space Engineering
University this is a major step forward
for the government and for Canadian
research we know that in fact Canada has
been victim in the past of te by Chinese
entities of Canadian technology and so I
think this will help to to clarify uh
the rules of the game now any Canadian
researcher applying for some of the
billions of dollars available every year
in federal research grants can no longer
partner or have any Formal Connection
with those banned institutions or their
employees I'm glad to see that the now
researchers are paying more attention to
what is going on internal documents
obtained by the Canadian press indicated
that the government crafted the new
rules in a way to avoid stigmatizing
Chinese Canadians and Chinese foreign
students oh I think there will actually
be less ability to
stigmatize because there's more clarity
now Federal officials say this new
policy will affect only a small amount
of the research in Canada but it is one
of the First Federal initiatives to
specifically Target China Russia and
Iran the three countries which will
almost certainly be at the heart of the
hearings to be held by the public
inquiry into foreign interference when
it begins its work in two weeks Donna
all right David Aken in Ottawa thanks
David passionate acceptance speech next
how a Canadian Chef stole the show at
the
emys
goodby roll
Elton John has reached New Heights he is
now an egot that means he's won an Emmy
a Grammy an Oscar and a Tony Award the
legendary musician won an Emmy last
night for his farewell from Dodger
Stadium concert his final North American
Show comedian Ali Wong made Emmy history
last night she is the first woman of
Asian descent to win for a lead role
best actress in a limited series for her
role in beef and Quinta Brunson is the
first black woman to win best comedic
actress in more than 40 years she won
for her performance on Abbot Elementary
the bear also had a big night winning
six emys including outstanding comedy
series shot in Chicago it's about the
challenges of running a restaurant
Canadian Mattie mat knows all about that
he's one of the actors and a co-producer
he's also a real Chef who runs several
restaurants in Ontario and his
acceptance speech last night was wild
Mike Dray report reports for the big
Awards the star or Show creator usually
accepts the hardware not the quirky cast
member wearing sandals who grab the Emmy
and the kiss of the night but that's
Toronto Chef Maddie mat for you swear to
God I'm a good Chef You' never know cuz
I'm a
sociopath mat it seems is every bit the
hilarious Oddball in everything he
does my but he never comes across as
anything but genuine he may provide the
bear with some of its later moments I
dare you know what actually I dare you I
dare now I dare you call Mom I dare you
call Mom I'm going to call call Mom call
see what happens she can't hear you but
as a real Chef he also consults on the
show to give it authenticity mat hasn't
hid his past troubles he overcame
addiction and a heart attack to build a
series of successful restaurants and his
partner at maker pizza in Toronto says
what he brought to the bear is what he
took from his life there's like a very
weird science to Running a Restaurant
and they've depicted that like it's
pretty much bang on it can be hard
sometimes to distinguish fiction from
reality I got Hearth but isn't that the
chef actor recipe for Success mro light
Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna Freez and we
leave you with another tribute to food
when Edmonton was in a deep deep freeze
how cold was it well this egg froze as
it hit the frying pan and this bowl of
ramen would need a spell in the mic away
before it warmed your soul a winter
might as well embrace it and get
creative thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye